[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vols à destination de djerba djerba la
douce merci pnc aux portes
tous les passagers sont invités à
prendre l'escalier b c d e f
[Applaudissements]
le mec qui sera complètement frère je
connais quand tu te rases horrible et ça
paye ça c'est le dimanche soir c'est au
mas des fracas ce type la journée ils
avaient un temps de chien tu vas grâce à
deux bras et tu y arrives asie ni comeau
que mon frère j'ai rasé moi mais ça
connaît par coeur l'histoire et tu
commences à te diras tu dis je vais
faire genre deux minutes tu commences
merde j'ai raté c'est exactement ça et
là frère et là il ya un tournant
et là tu commences à vouloir combler le
trou donc tu vas fischer tu vas
commencer à faire un trou ici à préférer
à baba tu as une tante et mon frère de
ou fernando fait c'est quoi
pas mauvais tours à faire le tu vois ma
ba que tu as une te tais meyers
trophique dégueulasse tu prends 200 kg
mon père je ne peux plus de julie
raynaud la protectrice dans l'oreillette
sur décoller on dirait que je vais faire
décoller un avion depuis lors je ne sais
pas quand même pas le frère ennemi n
importe quoi mais les césars jeumont car
le cul l'air là je suis protégé là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle commence au basket à temps ouais
ouais pratique
pierrick mary quant au dehors de trois
heures de trois airs au dessus de
public.fr encore plus de la merde c'est
voici.fr c'est de la chiasse voilà voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est cyril puis benjamin et c'est bon
j'ai décidé de faire cette très bon en
tout cas final très bien ça nous va
magnifique
cyril première question pour un point en
audiovisuel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]